This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。人类的绝对保证。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，我将带您剖析坚韧不拔的意志、健康体魄以及复原力的养成。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些磨难，你就会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们约会过的对象竟然都是同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听。欢迎收听《回溯往昔》播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。对我也一样，84年很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，盘点当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过那段日子的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that. you need to listen to learn the hard way on the iha radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《回溯往昔》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学步》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个栏目聚焦于黑人群体的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不安全、无法开展的坦诚对话。在这里，你将与一位深谙其道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披重铠。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力。你就得这样做。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《艰难学步》
podcast hello everybody welcome back to the show welcome back to the podcast new listeners old listeners wherever you are in the world it's so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of your 20s we have a guest on today that i i pursued i'm going to say it that way. I pursued her. Sorry, Ellie. I just spoiled who you are, but you would have read it in the title. I was like, I need this person on for this topic. She is the perfect person to discuss this, to discuss ADHD, autism in our 20s. She has such a unique story and an incredible voice to this matter that I think is both personal but also very informed and a little bit different. So welcome Ellie Middleton. It's so great to have you here. Thank you so much. So nice to be here.
大家好，欢迎回到本节目，欢迎回到本播客。无论你是新听友还是老听友，无论你身处世界的哪一个角落，很高兴能陪伴大家开启新的一期节目。今天我们将剖析二十多岁时的心理学，我们今天请到了一位嘉宾，我是说，我是主动去邀请她的。我要这么说。我主动追求了她。抱歉，艾莉。我刚刚剧透了你的身份，不过你们在标题里应该已经看到了。当时我想，探讨这个话题必须得请这个人来。她是讨论这个话题的最佳人选，来探讨我们二十多岁时的ADHD（注意力缺陷多动障碍）和自闭症。她有着非常独特的经历，并为这个话题发出了不可思议的声音，我认为这既具有个人色彩，又非常专业，而且有些与众不同。所以，欢迎艾莉·米德尔顿。很高兴你能来到这里。非常感谢。很高兴来到这里。
Thanks for the lovely introduction. I feel like I always sit here like blushing at the style and people are saying nice things about me. I'm like, oh yeah, that's me. Thank you so much. No, I get that. It's something you kind of have to learn to take sometimes. But imagine if someone sat here and I was like, yeah, I'm not that keen on this. Like, thanks for coming on, I guess.
谢谢你这么暖心的介绍。我觉得每次坐在这里，听到别人说我的好话，我都忍不住脸红，心想：“噢，天哪，真的是我吗？”非常感谢。不，我懂的。有时候你确实得学会接受这些赞美。但想象一下，如果有人坐在这里，然后我说：“好吧，其实我没那么喜欢这个。”就好像：“谢啦，谢天谢地你来参加。”
Like that would be seen even more embarrassing. Yeah, that's true. And you're calling in from the UK. So we got like an international podcast crew going on here. Yeah, I know, worldwide. I know, Mrs. Worldwide's here. So I kind of introduced you briefly. You're Ellie Middleton.
那感觉会更尴尬。嗯，确实如此。你是从英国打来的电话。所以我们这里有一个国际化的播客制作团队。对啊，没错，世界级的。没错，全球先生……哦不，全球女士在这里。所以我刚刚简单地介绍了一下你。你是艾莉·米德尔顿。
You have this incredible story. You've just released a book on Mast, which is available in the UK right now. Hopefully by the time people are listening to this internationally, because it's incredible. But for those of the listeners who don't know you, can you just talk briefly about who you are, your story, your work,
你有着如此不可思议的经历。你刚刚在Mast出版了一本书，目前在英国已经上市了。希望当国际上的听众听到这期节目时，这本书也已经能在全球买到了，因为它真的很棒。但对于那些还不了解你的听众，你能简要谈谈你是谁、你的故事、你的工作吗？
kind of a free space to just chat Ellie, I guess. Yeah, thank you. So yeah, I'm Ellie. I'm an autistic and ADHD content creator, speaker and writer. So I guess the short version is that I got diagnosed with both ADHD and autism when I was 24. So up until that point, I'd always struggled with my mental health, had quite a rough time in my teenage years, but I'd always been diagnosed with generalised anxiety disorder and like anxiety-related depression and panic disorder and agoraphobia and all that good stuff in the mental health. space. But then when I was kind of 24, kind of realized that that didn't seem to really fit. Like it wasn't really explaining my experiences properly. Like I wasn't an anxious person. I just became really overwhelmed really frequently. So it wasn't like anxiety. It was
这就当是一个畅所欲言、随性聊聊的空间吧，艾莉。好的，谢谢。好的，我是艾莉。我是一名患有自闭症和ADHD的内容创作者、演讲者兼作家。所以，长话短说，我是在24岁时被诊断出同时患有ADHD和自闭症的。因此，在此之前，我的心理健康一直不太好，青少年时期过得挺艰难的。但以前我总是被诊断为广泛性焦虑障碍、焦虑相关抑郁症、惊恐障碍以及广场恐惧症等等，心理健康领域里那些常见的毛病。但后来当我大概24岁的时候，我突然意识到这些诊断似乎并不太对劲。它们并没有真正准确地解释我的经历。我并不是一个焦虑的人，我只是非常频繁地感到极度不知所措。所以那不是焦虑，而是
overwhelmed. But I think those two things are so closely linked that all the doctors that I'd seen in the past had kind of just assumed that it was anxiety. But yeah, anyway, when I was 24, I finally got diagnosed with both autism and ADHD and getting those diagnosis just like changed my life completely. Like it just made everything made sense. It made me kind of understand who I was. And I kind of, I guess I just felt so grateful that I got those answers that I was like, oh my goodness, like I can finally like be myself now. I can finally like work out how to make my mental health better, like all of this stuff that I just felt that there must be so many other people out there, especially women who were like in the same boat that I was. So they like had always
不堪重负。但我认为这两者紧密相连，以至于我以前看过的所有医生都下意识地认为那就是焦虑。不过不管怎样，当我24岁时，我终于被确诊患有自闭症和ADHD，而得到这些诊断彻底改变了我的生活。它让一切都变得有迹可循。它让我开始理解真正的自己。而且我猜，我当时感到无比庆幸，终于得到了这些答案，我心想：“天哪，我终于可以做真正的自己了。我终于可以找出改善自己心理健康的方法了。”这一切让我觉得，外面的世界里一定还有很多人，特别是那些处境跟我一样的女性，她们也
been diagnosed with anxiety. They knew that they were different somehow. They knew that something else was going on but they just didn't know what that thing was and they just never had been picked up by their doctors or their teachers or whatever it might be. So I started speaking about it online just like hoping like knowing that like if I'd have seen me speaking about it like have a few years earlier then it would have been like oh that kind of sounds similar to me so maybe I should look into that as well and maybe I would have got diagnosed like a whole lot sooner than I actually did. And so kind of wanted to try and at least like just make one person think oh maybe that that could be me and I could go away and look into that as well and then it all kind of spiraled from there I guess
一直被诊断为焦虑。她们知道自己与众不同，知道有什么不对劲，但又不知道究竟是什么，而且从未被医生、老师或是其他人注意到。所以我开始在网上分享这些，就怀着一种微小的希望——我知道，如果几年前我看到有人在谈论这些，我就会想：“哦，这听听起来跟我有点像，也许我也该去了解一下。”也许我能比实际确诊的时间早得多就知道这一切了。所以，我只想试着至少让一个人产生这样的想法：“哦，也许这也正是我身上的情况，我也许可以去了解一下。”然后事情就这么一发不可收拾了，我想大概就是这样。
so I kind of very quickly grew quite a big audience online and then I go into quite a lot of companies talking about how they can be more inclusive and then yeah as very kindly mentioned I've just written a book about it which is like my baby is like the proudest thing that I've ever done I'm so happy with it I'm so grateful that I've had the chance to do it but yeah I guess basically um I shout about the importance of like understanding the way that your brain works and like being gentle with yourself, but also kind of advocate for people having the chance to get those answers because so many people like women, people marginalised for their gender, people of colour, queer people especially are spending so much of their lives undiagnosed and just kind of
所以，我的网络粉丝群体增长得非常快，后来我也受邀到很多公司去演讲，谈论他们该如何做到更具包容性。然后，正如刚才非常客气地提到的那样，我刚刚写了一本关于这方面的书。它就像我的亲生骨肉一样，是我做过的最让我引以为豪的事情。我对它超级满意，也非常感激能有这样一次机会。不过是的，基本上……我大声疾呼理解大脑运作方式的重要性，要对自己温柔一点，同时我也倡导人们应该有机会去寻找这些答案。因为有太多的人——比如女性、性别边缘化群体、有色人种，尤其是酷儿群体——他们生命中的大部分时间都处于未确诊的状态，
being missed completely by the system. So it's like on us to advocate for ourselves. So yeah, that's a long and short version, I guess. I love it. It's really interesting what you said, what you just said about how you had this litany of diagnoses before. you got to the right one. And I don't know if that's even the right way of saying it. Like, it's almost like, the answer seems quite obvious now, I'm sure. Like, you're probably questioning, like, how come no one ever said this to me? How come it was never an option? How come it was never on the table? I'm sure that must have been so frustrating. And speaking from, like, the experience of friends, I was saying I had a close friend who was recently diagnosed. And when you said,
并且完全被医疗系统所忽略。所以，为自己发声的责任落在了我们自己身上。好了，这就是长话短说的版本，我想差不多就是这样。我太喜欢了。你刚才说的话真的很有意思，你提到在得到正确的诊断之前，你曾经历过一系列的诊断。我甚至不知道用“正确”这个词是否准确。就好像，现在回想起来，答案似乎相当明显了，我敢肯定，你可能也会在心里打问号：“为什么从来没有人跟我说过这个？为什么它从来不是一个选项？为什么它从来没被摆上台面过？”那种感觉一定非常令人沮丧。从朋友的经历来看，我曾说过我有一位挚友最近刚被确诊。当你说
everyone just told me I was anxious. I just immediately thought of her and how much that that was always the reason given to her for this pattern of behaviours, this pattern of tendencies. And it wasn't the right answer and no one thought to look deeper into it. It must be like so immensely frustrating. Yeah, I think there's like a couple of stories in particular from my like childhood and teenage years that I look back now and I'm like, how the heck did nobody like notice what was going on there. Like there's one, I think my mum, like, struggles with this one a lot. Like, I think she feels a lot of guilt when I, so I'm an August baby, so I was always the youngest in my year group. In the UK, our year groups run for, I don't know if it's the same of there, but we run from like September to
“每个人都只告诉我我是焦虑”时，我立刻想到了她，以及这个原因是如何一次又一次地被用来解释她的一系列行为模式和性格倾向。然而这并不是正确的答案，也没有人想过要深入探究。那感觉一定极其令人沮丧。是的，我觉得在我的童年和青少年时期，确实有几个特别的故事。现在回想起来，我都会忍不住想：天哪，当时怎么就没人注意到到底是怎么回事呢？有一个故事，我妈妈每次想起这个都觉得挺难受的。我觉得当我提起它时，她总是会感到很内疚。我是八月份出生的，所以我一直是我那个年级里年龄最小的。在英国，我们的学年是——我不知道那边是不是也这样——我们是从九月一直到
August, so I'm like the youngest in my year. And when I was at nursery, so I was like three and the rest of the kids in my year were four and we were about to go up to primary school. And the nursery teacher, like, pulled my mum in and was like, okay, academically, Ellie's definitely ready to go up to school, like she's really bright. She knows what's going on. But socially, you might want to consider holding her back a year. Like, she's very shy. She doesn't really interact with the other kids. Like, she's just not really interested. Like, we try to encourage her to play in their games and do all these different things. But all she really wants to do is, like, she just comes in every day. And I would, like, sit in the same room on the same table and just do, like, painting every single
八月，所以我算是年级里最小的。当我上幼儿园时，我大概三岁，年级里的其他孩子都四岁了，我们正准备升入小学。幼儿园老师把我妈妈叫过去谈话，对方说：“嗯，从学业上讲，艾莉绝对已经准备好上小学了，她非常聪明，对事情很有理解力。但在社交方面，您可能需要考虑让她留级一年。她非常害羞，不太和别的孩子互动，好像也没什么兴趣。我们尝试鼓励她参与他们的游戏，做各种不同的事情，但她真正想做的是，每天来幼儿园时，我都坐在
day. And that was all I was interested in. And I look back at that now. And it was kind of just like, oh, okay, well, you know, she's just a youngest girl in the year. So she's just a bit shy. Like, it'll be fine, it'll come with age, like it's no, like, no worry. She's just like a shy little girl. And I look back and I'm like, if that was like Elliot, rather than Ellie or Ethan, or whatever it might be, like a little boy, a young boy that is like very academically bright, but struggles socially does the same thing every single day. Like, I don't know, he's lining up his dinosaurs in a row every single day. He doesn't want to talk to anybody. They've tried to encourage him to. Like straight away, that would be like alarm bells. They'd be looking into it.
同一个房间的同一张桌子旁，日复一日地画画。”这就是她唯一感兴趣的事。现在回想起来，当时大家的态度大概就是：“哦，好吧，你知道的，她只是年级里最小的女孩，所以有点害羞，没关系，随着年龄增长就好了，没什么好担害的，她只是个害羞的小女孩。”但现在回想起来我就想，如果当时是个男孩——叫埃利奥特而不是艾莉，或者叫伊森，或者其他什么名字——一个学业非常聪明、但在社交上有困难、而且每天都在做同一件事情的小男孩，比如，假设他每天都在把自己的恐龙玩具排成一排，不想跟任何人说话，即使别人试着鼓励他。
They'd be trying to find out what was going on. They'd be thinking that was autism. but because it was a little girl, it was like, oh, she's just a bit shy, like it's fine, she's just a young girl. And it's like, that was like, I was three years old at that point. Like, if I'd have been diagnosed at that point or even had it looked into at that point, like, my whole life could have been so much different. And then there's like kind of similar stories in high school where teachers were saying that like, I was being had a really hard time, like socially and was kind of being
那立刻就会敲响警钟。大家就会去调查原因，会试图弄清楚发生了什么，会认为这可能是自闭症。但因为是个小女孩，大家的反应就是：“哦，她只是有点害羞，没关系，她只是个小女孩嘛。”这就好比，我当时才三岁。如果那个时候我被诊断出来，甚至哪怕当时有人去关注一下，我整个人生可能会完全不同。后来在高中也有类似的故事。老师们说我在社交上过得很艰难，遭遇了相当严重的霸凌。
bullied quite badly. And one of my teachers had said like, oh, well, Ellie says things that are rude sometimes. so she can't like be upset when other people are rude back to her. And my mom was like, well, what does she say that's rude? Because like she's not, she's not a nasty person. Like she wouldn't, she wouldn't do that. And then they were like, oh, well, she had got like an A rather than an A star in one of her exams. And she was kind of saying to the other girls like, oh, I'm so annoyed that I didn't get the A star that I wanted.
其中一位老师曾说：“哦，嗯，艾莉有时候说话挺伤人的，所以当别人对她不礼貌时，她不能感到难过。”我妈妈就问：“那她到底说了什么伤人的话？因为她不是那种刻薄的人，她绝不会做出那种事。”然后他们说：“哦，是这样的，她在某次考试中拿了A，而不是A星。然后她跟其他几个女孩说：‘哎呀，我没拿到自己想要的A星，我好沮丧啊。’”
Whereas some of the other girls had struggled to scrape a C or a D. And they were like, that's kind of, you know, inappropriate. You shouldn't be saying that. And I was like, well, I didn't know that that was rude. like I'm not saying that they should have got an A or a star. I'm just saying that I'm upset with myself and not being able to read those social cues is like a key sign of autism as well. But instead it was like, oh no, she's just rude. She's just a bitch.
而当时班上有些其他女同学为了及格都费尽了力气，考个C或D都很艰难。他们就觉得：“这有点不合时宜，你不应该这么说。”而我的想法是：“我当时并不知道这样说是不礼貌的，我并不是说她们应该考个A或A星，我只是在为自己没考好感到难过。”无法解读这些社交暗示其实也是自闭症的一个关键特征，但他们没有这么想，而是觉得：“哦不，她就是粗鲁，她就是个碧池。”
She's just whatever. Like I think so much of it is closely tied to misogyny, unfortunately. But yeah, I think looking back, there's like so many things where it is like, yeah, what the heck? Like it was literally like, I may as well have had a neon sign flashing above my head that was like, this gal is autistic. but no one like ever kind of considered that that was what was going on. It's so interesting you point to misogyny and how, I think one of the deepest problems in how we approach neurodivergents, particularly ADHD and autism, is that the entire diagnoses criteria is built around the behaviour of boys and the behavior
她就是个怎样怎样的人。我觉得很大程度上，这不幸地与厌女症密切相关。但回想起来，真的有太多这样的事情，让你觉得：“天哪，怎么会这样？”我就差在头上顶个霓虹灯牌闪烁着“此女有自闭症”了，但就是没有人哪怕考虑过这可能是怎么回事。你指出厌女症以及我们对待神经多样性的方式中存在的最深层问题之一，这真的太有意思了，特别是针对ADHD和自闭症，整个诊断标准完全是围绕着男孩和男人的行为来建立的
of men. And we know that culturally, those two, you know, binaries that society often sees, they're raised different. They are taught differently as to how to behave, their personalities, their temperaments are different. But when you have this kind of systematic bias in the healthcare system, it's no wonder that people such as yourself slip through. And it's kind of a tragedy. And I know the things that you've done now are so amazing. But what if you had the opportunity to start at that earlier? What if you had had that opportunity to actually get the help you need, not experience so much self-blame and negative self-belief when you were three, when you were 10,
。我们都知道，在文化层面上，社会常常看到的这两种二元性别，他们的抚养方式是不同的。他们的教育方式、行为举止、性格和气质都不一样。但是，当医疗系统存在这种系统性偏见时，像你这样的人被漏诊也就不足为奇了。这简直是个悲剧。我知道你现在做的事情非常了不起，但如果你当年有机会更早开始呢？如果你当初有机会得到真正需要的帮助，而不是在三岁、十岁、十五岁时去承受那么多的自我责怪和消极的自我暗示……我确信那一定非常难熬。所以我想你其实已经谈到了这一点，但你认为为什么特别是那么多女性很难获得诊断，很难让她们的症状得到识别？与之相伴的是，为什么在人们考虑其他可能性、其他潜在情况之前，总是先给她们贴上焦虑症的诊断标签呢？
when you were 15, like I'm sure that's really rough. So I think you've kind of already touched on it, but why do you think so many women in particular struggle to receive a diagnosis, have their symptoms recognized, and kind of alongside that, why is it always that they get the anxiety diagnosis first before people consider other options, other potential things going on? Yeah, I think like you kind of nailed it really well there that the diagnostic criteria is just not set up to account for the experiences of women, the experiences of people marginalized for their gender, the experiences of people of colour, they're based on basically like the easy way to explain it is like the only people that these psychologists were basing the research on was like the young middle class white boys whose parents could afford, basically if they had a young boy that wasn't behaving in the way that they wanted him to, they would pay to take him to this private psychiatrist, and then they were the people that the research was based on. So anyone outside of that, their experiences are just not accounted for in the diagnostic criteria. So I think one example,
是的，就像你刚才说的那样，诊断标准根本没有考虑到女性的经历、因性别而被边缘化之人的经历、有色人种的经历。它们基本上是基于——用最简单的话来解释——这些心理学家当时进行研究的唯一对象，是一群年轻的中产阶级白人男孩，他们的父母能够负担得起费用。基本上，如果他们有一个行为不合心意的男孩，他们就会花钱带他去看私立精神病医生，而这就是那些研究的基础群体。所以，任何在这个群体之外的人，她们的经历在诊断标准中完全没有被考量进去。所以，举个例子，
like for me, this is a question that I had to answer as a 24-year-old woman trying to get diagnosed. And the question is like, you know, say if this is like highly, highly true, a bit true, not true or slightly true whatever and it's like i collect information about categories of things for example types of birds types of planes types of car types of plants or something so me reading that question i'm like well no i don't i don't collect information about any of those type of things and then like the more research you do it's like well yeah that's because i'm not an eight-year-old boy i'm a 24-year-old woman like i collect information about i don't know if i like a certain band i will listen to their albums over and over and over again.
对我来说，这是我作为一个24岁试图确诊的女性必须回答的一个问题。这个问题是这样的：比如，如果以下情况高度符合、有点符合、不符合或略微符合等等——“我收集关于各类事物的资料，例如：各种鸟类、各种飞机、各种汽车、各种植物之类的。”我读到这个问题时心想：“没有啊，我才不收集这些东西的资料呢。”然后随着你做越来越多的研究，就会发现：“哦，对啊，那是因为我不是八岁的小男孩，我是24岁的女性。我收集的资料是……比如说，如果我喜欢某个乐队，我会一遍又一遍地听他们的专辑。”
If I like a certain fashion creator, I will constantly be checking to see if they've uploaded new content because I want to see what's going on. Or if I like a certain clothes brand, then I will be obsessed with when the new drops are coming out and checking the website and wanting everything to do. Like, I do still do the same thing of like having these really strong interests that I become like obsessed with.
如果我喜欢某个时尚博主，我会不断查看他们有没有上传新内容，因为我想看看有什么新鲜事。或者如果我喜欢某个服装品牌，我就会对他们什么时候上新产生执念，疯狂刷他们的官网，想要了解和购买与之一切相关的东西。你看，我确实还在做同样的事情，也就是对某些特定的兴趣产生强烈的痴迷。
But they're just not birds, cars, trains or planes because they're very like stereotypically, like, young boy interests. And I think that's like a really good example of like just how much the diagnostic criteria is not designed. Like it's like you could sit there as a fully like 100% autistic person and still get a really like low score on these tests that they're doing just because the questions don't explain your experience.
只不过它们不是鸟类、汽车、火车或飞机，因为那些是非常刻板印象中的“小男孩兴趣”。我认为这是一个很好的例子，说明了诊断标准的设计有多么脱离实际。这就好像，你可以作为一个百分之百的自闭症患者坐在那里，但在做这些测试时仍然只能得到很低的分数，仅仅因为这些问题根本无法解释你的经历。
And there's other ones where it's like, would you prefer to go to a museum or to a party? and obviously it what well I guess the correct answer is like they think that you'd rather go to a museum as an autistic person and it's like well it kind of depends on on the museum like am I going to party with friends yeah like it's like am I going like what sort of party is it am I going with friends am I going with strangers like it's like that question does not in any way kind of explain whether I'm autistic or not and I think it's the same like with ADHD as well that like I think it's like this like this like see blonde stereotype is one that I speak about in the book quite a lot, which I think is a reason why a lot of girls go undiagnosed. Because, I mean, previously it was kind of said that a lot more girls would have like the inattentive type of ADHD, which is the more like forgetfulness and struggling to concentrate and doodling and rather than the hyperactive type, which is more like outwardly visible, I guess. So that was kind of an idea of like, well, they're presenting a different type of ADHD, which isn't as outwardly visible. But I think that,
还有其他类似的问题，比如：“你更喜欢去博物馆还是去参加派对？”显然后者的正确答案是……或者说他们认为作为一个自闭症患者，你更愿意去博物馆。但这就有点取决于是什么博物馆了：我是和朋友一起去派对吗？对，这就变成……是去什么样的派对？我是和朋友一起去，还是和陌生人一起去？所以这个问题根本无法在任何层面上说明我到底是不是自闭症患者。我觉得ADHD也是一样的道理。我在书里经常谈到一个叫作“金发碧眼女孩刻板印象”的概念，我认为这是很多女孩得不到诊断的原因。因为，以前人们常常说，更多的女孩会表现出“注意力缺陷型”的ADHD，也就是更容易健忘、难以集中注意力、喜欢涂鸦，而不是“多动冲动型”那种外在表现更明显的情况。所以这曾是一种观点，即她们呈现的是不同类型的ADHD，其外在表现没有那么明显。但我认为，
we've kind of moved on from that as well to be like maybe they're not presenting any differently like the experiences that they have aren't any differently um they're just socialized in a different way like i'm hyperact i have combined ADHD which means i'm both hyperactive and inattentive but my hyperactivity is very much internal like my brain is like a million miles an hour all of the time so it wasn't ever at school that i was like rocking backwards and forwards on my chair like causing chaos, like the teachers were like finding me annoying all of this stuff because girls are told to behave, to be quiet, whereas boys, it's like, oh, boys will be boys, like they're allowed to be a bit more chaotic and girls are very much socialised to, to fit in, to be well-behaved,
我们现在对这个问题的看法已经有所发展，也许她们的表现形式并没有什么不同，她们的经历也没有什么两样，她们只是受到了不同的社会化教育。我是混合型的ADHD，这意味着我既有多动倾向又有注意力不集中倾向，但我的多动非常内在——我的大脑无时无刻不在以每小时一百万英里狂飙。所以在学校里，我从来没有在椅子上前后摇晃、制造混乱，也没有让老师觉得我很烦人或者做出其他类似的出格行为。因为女孩从小被教育要乖巧、要安静，而男孩则会被认为“男孩子嘛，难免调皮”，他们被允许表现得更具破坏性一点，而女孩则被社会化得必须融入集体、表现良好、
to be polite, to be sensible, to be like so much more mature, I guess, like typically. So I think it's like a combination of the fact that like one, when not getting diagnosed at a young age, because the diagnostic criteria aren't accounting for how we show up. And then secondly, because we're not like learning that we're different at a young age, we're then being socialized in the way that kind of this patriarchal system socializes all of like women and people marginalize for their gender. So by the time, like by the time we get any older, we're not showing any differences because we've learned how to mask them and cover them up.
举止礼貌、懂事体贴，相比之下往往要成熟得多。所以我觉得这是两方面结合的结果：第一，我们在年轻时没有被确诊，因为诊断标准没有把我们的表现形式纳入考量；第二，因为我们从小没有意识到自己与众不同，所以我们接受了这种将所有女性和性别边缘化群体塑造得循规蹈矩的父权制系统的社会化规训。因此，到了我们年纪再大一些的时候，我们表面上看起来就没有任何不同了，因为我们已经学会了如何伪装和掩饰它们。
Like my mom, we have like a lot of conversations where it is obviously that thing of like the grief, I guess, of getting diagnosed later in life where it's like, what could have been? Like, I had to drop out of school. I had to decline my uni offers. Like, I've had to quit jobs, all of this stuff. And I'm like, that wouldn't have happened if I'd have been diagnosed early. And, like, we've had the conversation with my mum where my mum has been like, but when I was 15 was when I, like, first got referred to the mental health services in the UK.
我妈妈和我经常进行这样的对话，谈到晚确诊带来的那种悲伤——“如果当初……”比如我不得不辍学，不得不放弃大学录取通知书，不得不辞掉工作，经历这一切。而我会想：“如果我早点被确诊，这些都不会发生。”我们和我妈妈聊过这件事，我妈妈说：“可是当我15岁的时候，正是我在英国第一次被转诊到心理健康服务机构的时候。”
And at that point, they wouldn't have been able to, like, I'm like, I'm like, Like how could they not have seen? Like I was seeing a psychiatrist every week. Like how like how could they have not noticed that that was what was going on for me? And it's like, well, by that point, they wouldn't have been able to see it in you because you were doing such a good job of covering it up. Like by that time you'd have like, you were in high school, you'd learn that you had to fit in. You had to make friends. You had to survive.
在那个节点上，他们本来应该能够……我就想：“他们怎么会看不出来呢？我每周都去看精神科医生，他们怎么会没注意到我身上发生了什么呢？”答案是，到那个时候，他们在你身上已经看不出来了，因为你把自己的真实状态隐藏得太好了。到了那个时候，你已经在高中里学会了如何融入集体，学会了如何交朋友，学会了如何生存。
So you weren't showing any differences for them to pick up on all that they were being able to visibly see was the fact that you were having these like meltdowns and shutdowns and becoming overwhelmed. because it was almost like you were keeping it all in for such a long time that then it had all just like burst out in these like intense things that would look a lot like panic attacks because it was just that I like would become so overwhelmed I wouldn't be able to speak I would be crying I'd be overwhelmed and it's like well that's all that they had to work with because they couldn't see all of that that you were holding it in like containing it most of the time they just saw these kind of like volcano eruptions of when it came out and so yeah I think it's a really it all like ties into it.
所以你没有表现出任何让别人能捕捉到的异常。他们肉眼能看到的，仅仅是你经历了这些精神崩溃、情感关机，变得不堪重负。因为这几乎就像是你把所有的情绪都死死压抑了太久，然后它们终于在一系列强烈的事件中彻底爆发了，看起来非常像恐慌发作，因为你实在是承受了太多，以至于无法开口说话，只能不停地哭泣，陷入彻底崩溃。而这正是他们唯一能看到的状况，因为他们看不到你在背后默默忍耐、极力克制的大部分时间，他们只看到了火山爆发般的崩溃瞬间。所以是的，我觉得这一切都是息息相关的。
as well and it's like equally as well the more that the diagnostic criteria only account for the experiences of these like young white cis boys the more that they're the only people that do get diagnosed so it's like they're the only people that are going about life with the diagnosis yeah so then it's like that kind of reinforces it of like they're the only people like the only people that you would meet I guess that would know that they were autistic and ADHD is those people so then in your head you're like oh well everyone that I've met that's autistic is a young white boy so maybe it's just young white boys and it kind of goes like it goes on for such a long time like now I think we're seeing a wave of like yeah people in their 20s 30s 40s getting a diagnosis and
而且同样地，诊断标准越是只把这些年轻白人顺性别男孩的经历作为参考，他们就越成为唯一能被诊断出患有此病的人。这就变成了一个循环：他们是唯一带着诊断结果在这个世界上生活的人。于是这又进一步强化了这种印象：“我见过的所有自闭症和ADHD患者都是年轻白人男孩，所以也许这只是年轻白人男孩的专利。”这种误解持续了很长时间。不过现在，我觉得我们正在迎来一波新的浪潮，无论是20多岁、30多岁还是40多岁的人，都在获得诊断，
realizing for themselves and you know whether that's medical diagnosis or self-diagnosing or all of these things like but they're realizing later in life and I think that's amazing that we're like catching all of these people that were missed but I still don't know if we're getting any better at picking up the girls like the Elliott three like I don't yeah I still it's almost like it's like yeah, it's amazing that we're finding out now, but we need to fix it. So we don't have to find out. Like the next group of people don't have to find out in their 20s. They find out at the same time.
为自己解开心结。不管这是通过医学诊断、自我诊断还是其他什么途径，人们在晚年终于意识到了真相。我认为能够找出所有这些曾经被漏诊的人，是一件非常了不起的事情。但我仍然不确定我们是否真的在更擅长捕捉像小时候的艾莉、三岁的小女孩那样的病例。是的，我依然觉得，虽然我们现在才发现这一点很棒，但我们需要解决根本问题，这样未来的群体就不必等到20多岁才去寻找答案了，她们本该在适当的时候就知道。
Yeah, it's a really like tricky one, I think, to fix without, they basically just need to like redo the whole research and the whole diagnostic criteria, I guess. It honestly sounds like that. And also like to avoid that grief that you spoke about. But from what you've said, it's like, yeah, it doesn't account for differences in gender in sex, in ethnicity, in really anything. And then it also sounds like they kind of haven't adapted it for like a new generation that has a new environment, like social media, like technology.
是的，我觉得这是一个非常棘手的问题，如果不从根本上重新做研究、重写整个诊断标准，大概很难彻底解决。听上去确实如此。而且还能避免你所说的那种遗憾。但根据你所说的一切，它确实没有考虑到性别、生理性别、种族等任何层面的差异。听起来他们也没有为了新环境下的新一代人——比如社交媒体、科技的发展——去对标准进行调整。
And something you said really stood out for me there. It was going online and following a certain influencer or following a certain fashion company. That is a whole new way of kind of processing our environment and how symptoms might show up. And I think that that profile that we spoke about is only going to be exacerbated if you don't have those nuances, not just for different groups, but for different generations that are also growing up more aware of it. The final thing that I think is actually really interesting, if you've ever spent much time looking into neurodivergence, ADHD, autism, but autism in particular, the idea of masking is really fascinating. And your book is unmasked. Fabulous title, big shout out to that.
你刚才说的话里有一点非常触动我。那就是上网关注某个特定的博主或时尚公司。这是一种处理我们所处环境以及症状可能如何表现的全新方式。我认为，如果我们不考虑这些细微差别，不仅是对不同的群体，而且是对也在以更高意识成长的不同世代而言，我们刚才谈到的那种画像只会进一步加剧。最后一件我认为非常有趣的事情是，如果你曾花时间深入研究过神经多样性、ADHD、自闭症，尤其是自闭症，那么“面具（masking）”这个概念真的非常迷人。你的书名叫《卸下面具（Unmasked）》。绝佳的书名，必须为它疯狂打Call。
But can you explain what that means? Because I think that a lot of the time, and this is one of my biggest pet peeves with discussions in the mental health community, is that terms that actually have a real clinical and personal meaning for people get adapted to mean something a lot more colloquial and a lot more every day. So for people who've maybe heard that term don't know what it means, what does it mean to mask? What does it mean to unmask, I guess, as well? Yeah, so masking put very kind of simply is covering up your neurodivergent traits to appear more neurotypical. So it was typically and like first used by the autistic community. So basically covering up your autistic traits to appear illistic or non-autistic.
但你能解释一下这是什么意思吗？因为我觉得很多时候——这也是我在心理健康社群讨论中最看不惯的一点——那些对人们具有真正的临床和个人意义的术语，往往被改编得流于俗套、变得非常日常和口语化。所以，对于那些可能听过这个词却不知道它是什么意思的人来说，什么是“戴面具（masking）”？我想，什么是“卸下面具（unmasked）”，又意味着什么呢？是的，所以简单来说，“戴面具”就是掩盖你的神经多样性特质，让自己显得更像是神经典型（非神经多样性）人群。这个词最初是由自闭症社群使用并广为人知的。基本上就是掩盖你的自闭症特质，好让自己看起来像个非自闭症患者。
But I guess it's kind of, yeah, spread out to be used more widely by the neurodivergent community. But I guess the important thing is to say like it's not a choice a lot of the time. Like it's a safety thing of like I have grown up learning that I have to behave a certain way to be accepted to avoid being ostracized like to get through situations like and I think yeah it's both it's both conscious behaviors and like subconscious or unconscious behaviors. So it can be things that are super simple like for example as an autistic person I struggle with eye contact like eye contact to me just it feels like I'm literally you're staring into my soul like it feels so unconsored. comfortable. But when I was growing up, I was told you have to look at people in the eye when you're speaking to them. Like that's a polite thing to do. Like, look at me when I'm talking to you. Show me that you're listening to me. All of these things. So I just learn, okay, that's the right thing to do talking to people. So I would just force myself to do that. And that's just the way that I learned to behave, even though that's not a natural thing for me at all. But I almost didn't know
但我猜它现在已经逐渐扩展开来，被整个神经多样性社群更广泛地使用了。不过重要的一点是，这在很多时候并不是一种选择。这是一种出于安全考虑的行为，就像我从小到大逐渐意识到：“我必须表现得像某种特定样子，才能被大家接受，才能避免被孤立，才能顺利应付各种处境。”而且我认为这既包括有意识的行为，也包括下意识或无意识的行为。它可以是非常简单的举止，比如，作为一个自闭症患者，我不擅长眼神接触——对我来说，眼神接触感觉就像你在直视我的灵魂，那种感觉太不自在了。
at that point that it wasn't a natural thing for me because I didn't know that I was autistic. So it was like, oh, everyone must find it as uncomfortable. And everyone must just force themselves to do it because it's polite so I've got to do that as well. Interesting. So it can be like things as simple as that all the way through to things like the things that you're talking about. So we kind of touched on like before the special interest that autistic people have where you'd have like one topic that you like a ride and die for basically like you're
但在我成长的过程中，大人们总是告诉我：“你跟别人说话时必须看着人家的眼睛，这是礼貌的做法。我跟你说话时看着我，向我证明你在听我说话。”诸如此类。所以我只是学会了：“好吧，跟别人说话时这样做才是对的。”于是我强迫自己去那样做。这就是我学会表现自己的方式，尽管这对我来说一点也不自然。但在当时，我几乎
obsessed with this topic. You love it. You are so interested in it. But you might have learned that if you talk about it all the time, then people are like, God, can we talk about something else please? like, oh, not this again. Like, so you've learned to do the small talk that other people do, or you've learned that, I don't know, at high school,
不知道这对我来说是不自然的，因为我压根不知道自己有自闭症。所以我想：“哦，所有人一定都觉得这同样不舒服，所有人一定都为了礼貌而在强迫自己这样做，所以我也必须这么做。”太有意思了。所以它可以是像那样简单的事情，一直延伸到我们刚才谈论的那些方面。我们之前稍微聊过自闭症患者的“特殊兴趣”，也就是你会有一种你愿意为之生死相随、基本上就是
like when you're a teenager, like, oh, it's, we're supposed to talk about the boys that we fancy and we're supposed to talk about the clothes that we wear. And so I'll talk about those things instead because that people like me if I talk about those things. And like, yeah, it's like a whole range of experiences. And it's something that is so, I guess, ingrained as well. Like, for me, I guess I thought,
痴迷其中的话题。你热爱它，你对它充满了兴趣。但你可能已经学会了，如果你总是滔滔不绝地谈论这个，别人就会觉得：“天哪，我们能聊点别的吗？”或者“怎么又是这个？”于是你学会了进行别人那种闲聊，或者你学会了——我不知道，在高中时，
when I got my diagnosis that I was like woohoo like I'm unmasked now like I can be myself like I've learned that I'm ADHD I've learned that I'm autistic like here we go like I can be myself but still like to this day I mask so so heavily like now I'm I'm masking probably I'm like speaking in a way like my natural tone of voice is quite like blunt and quite monotonous whereas I've learned that that's not well received by it's not easy for people to listen to it's not easy to get my point across so I've kind of learnt to speak in a more up and down way in a more bubbly way but it's not me I'm not come on this call and being like I need to you know come on Ellie like let's put our best accent on and talk in this certain way it's just a natural thing that when I talk to people it it
当你是青少年的时候——“哦，我们应该谈论我们暗恋的男孩，我们应该谈论我们穿的衣服。”所以我会转而谈论这些事情，因为如果我聊这些，别人就会喜欢我。这涵盖了非常广泛的体验。而且它已经根深蒂固了。比如对我来说，我曾以为
comes out like this now because it's so ingrained in the way that I am and I think yeah that's something that I underestimated so much of like how difficult it would be to unmask like I think I was like you know I've got the answers now like here we go like let's be ourselves and and it's like actually no like it's it's so I don't even know who's under there really because I've spent my whole life being yeah some like being someone else and copying the people around me and doing what I've been told to do
当我确诊的时候，我会欢呼雀跃：“太好了，我卸下面具了，我可以做真正的自己了！我发现我有ADHD，我发现我有自闭症了，来吧，我可以做自己了！”但直到今天，我依然在大量地、沉重地戴着面具。现在我说话时……我的自然音调其实相当生硬、单调，但我已经学会了这种语气并不受欢迎，别人听着会觉得费劲，也无法很好地表达我的观点，所以我已经习惯了用一种抑扬顿挫的、更有生气的方式说话。但这并不是我。我并没有在接通这个电话时对自己说：“来吧，艾莉，让我们摆出最好的腔调，用这种特定的方式说话。”这只是自然而然发生的，现在我跟别人说话时
and it's like I don't even know how to be like it's so much easier to slip into this character that has been so defined and you've had 24 years of practicing this character to then actually being yourself which is like your real self is so much more like I don't know how to explain this like there's no black and white, really. It's very much more grey areas.
它就自然而然地冒出来了，因为它已经深深融入了我的骨子里。我觉得这是我严重低估的一件事——卸下面具到底有多难。我当时以为：“你知道的，我现在有答案了，来吧，让我们做自己。”但现实其实是：“不，实际上……我甚至不知道面具底下到底是谁。”因为我花了一辈子在扮演别人，在模仿周围的人，在做别人告诉我要做的事。
It's very nuanced. It's very flowing. Like, we're all, like, kind of fluid. Whereas that character was clearly defined. Like, this is what Ellie likes. This is what Ellie doesn't like. This is how Ellie behaves. This is how Ellie doesn't behave.
以至于我甚至不知道该怎么做自己。去滑入这个已经被清晰定义、并且你已经练习了24年的人设，要比真正做真实的自己容易得多。真实的自己要……我不知道该怎么解释这一点——真实自我里真的没有什么非黑即白，它有太多的灰色地带，
So it's so much easier to fall into that. Like, you've got the rules of how to behave. Whereas if you're trying to actually, I guess it's the same for everybody. When you're trying to be yourself, it's, you don't know exactly what that looks like. But I think it's the same for unmasking of like, I know that I naturally speak in a certain way
非常细腻，充满流动性。我们每个人其实都处于一种流动状态中。而那个角色却是被清晰定义的：这就是艾莉喜欢的，这就是艾莉不喜欢的，这就是艾莉的行为方式，这就是艾莉不会有的行为方式。
when I'm around other people. But how do I, like, I don't know how I speak naturally because I don't speak to myself when I'm at home on my own. Do I? Like, that's when I'm the most unmanced is when I'm at home on my own, not being perceived by other people, not interacting with other people. But then I'm not having conversations then because I'm on my own. So it's like, how do I even get to know that kind of thing?
所以，退回到那个角色要容易得多，因为你拥有行事的规则。而如果你试图真正地——我想这其实对所有人来说都一样——当你试图做自己时，你并不确切知道那是什么样子。但我认为卸下面具也是同样的道理：我知道我在和别人在一起时会自然地用某种特定方式说话。但我该如何……我甚至不知道自己自然状态下是怎么说话的，因为当我独自在家时，我不会自言自语，不是吗？那正是我最不需要戴面具的时候——当我独自在家、不被别人注视、不与别人互动的时候。但那样的话，我就不会进行任何对话，因为我是一个人在家。所以，我怎么可能去了解那种状态下的自己呢？
But yeah, I guess it's, that's the kind of a very long explanation, but basically covering up your neurodivorgent traits to appear neurotypical. And a lot of the time it's like, done without realizing or done for safety. Or I think it's like important to point out as well that like I'm quite lucky that I'm able to unmask in certain ways because I'm very like non-threatening, I guess.
但是，是的，我想这是一个非常长的解释，但基本上就是掩饰你的神经多样性特质来表现得像神经典型人群。很多时候，这就像是在不知不觉中完成的，或者是为了安全起见。或者我觉得有一点也很重要，那就是我很幸运能够在某些方面停止伪装，因为我猜我是一个非常没有威胁性的人。
Like I'm a small white woman. I, you know, I have got pretty privilege. I'm like quite slim. I'm quite small. Whereas like a six foot five black man can't do that in the same way that I can because where I'm stood outside rocking backwards and forwards,
比如我是一个身材娇小的白人女性。我，你知道的，我拥有外貌特权。我相当苗条。我相当娇小。而一个六英尺五英寸的黑人男性就不能像我那样做，因为当我站在外面前后摇晃时，
feeling stressed out and that's like, oh, look at this poor young lady who's having a difficult time. Whereas if a black man does the same thing, it's like he's getting aggressive, he's being dangerous, like that could be like,
感到压力重重，人们会觉得，哦，看这个正在经历困难的可怜年轻女士。然而，如果一个黑人男性做同样的事情，人们就会觉得他变得具有攻击性，他很危险，就像那可能会，
you know, that could be a real risk for his safety. It could end up in him being imprisoned. It could end up getting in really like dangerous situation. So unmasking is like a necessary thing for us to do to be able to be healthy because it is so draining, like covering yourself up all of the time without realizing. But it's also a huge privilege to be able to do that as well because it can be like perceived in different ways for different people
你知道的，那对他的安全来说可能是真正的风险。这最终可能会导致他入狱。这可能会导致陷入真正危险的境地。因此，停止伪装是我们为了保持健康而必须要做的事情，因为一直以来在不知不觉中掩饰自己实在是太消耗精力了。但这也是一种巨大的特权，能够做到这一点，因为对于不同的人来说，它可能会以不同的方式被看待，
depending on what you look like. It can, you know, be, yeah, like even me. Sometimes I've had times where I've been super tired and I've had loads going on. So I've been more en masse and I've kind of spoken. more bluntly to people without realizing just that I'm kind of my tank is so empty that I don't have it in me to like cover it up anymore and people have been like you know you're being rude like why are you being off with me and I'm like I'm not being off with you I'm just like all I've got in me to do right now is
取决于你的外表。它可能，你知道的，是的，甚至连我有时也有过这样的经历，当我超级疲惫并且有太多事情要处理时。所以我变得更加不加掩饰，我说话对人更直率了，却甚至没有意识到，只是我的能量槽太空了，我再也没有力气去掩饰了，然后人们就会觉得，你知道的，你很粗鲁，为什么你要对我不理不睬，而我会觉得我不是对你冷淡，我只是，我目前唯一能做到的就是
communicate in the most concise and like natural way whereas that can like be end up in people thinking that you're behaving in a certain way and yeah I think it's a it's a it's both like the thing that I guess a lot of people are aiming for being able to unmask but it's also comes with like dangers for certain people and it comes with being misunderstood and like maybe being kind of yeah yeah misunderstood I guess further discriminated against yeah I think that's the thing like that's so interesting when you said that I was like I actually had never thought about that before I've never thought about that and I think it's such an interesting thing once again an argument to retire the profile of like we it's it's so linked to not just misogyny like we've spoken about like racism like
以最简洁和自然的方式进行交流，然而这可能会导致人们认为你的行为方式有问题，是的，我认为这是一个，这既是许多人都在努力实现的目标——能够停止伪装，但它也伴随着对某些人的危险，伴随着被误解，可能还有点，是的，被误解，我猜会遭受进一步的歧视，是的，我觉得就是这样，这太有趣了，当你这么说的时候，我想我以前真的从没想过这一点，我从来没有想过这一点，而且我认为这是一件非常有趣的事情，再次成为了一个淘汰某种刻板印象的论据——我们，它不仅仅和厌女症有关，就像我们讨论过的，还有种族主义，
prejudice in so many in so many like intricate ways and I think also because we as a society have really been taught from a young age how you are supposed to act which has contributed to the masking right there is a
在如此多错综复杂的方面的偏见，而且我认为这也是因为我们作为一个社会，从小就被真正教导过应该如何表现，这直接促成了伪装，
I think very defined formula of like correctness and politeness that people are taught from a very young age that also means that not only have you kind of forced yourself to take upon what sounds like a character what sounds like a persona no wonder you don't know who's underneath that. You've been method acting for 24 years. Like, method acting to like an A plus standard, like, to the point where doctors couldn't even see through it.
我认为存在一个非常明确的正确和礼貌的公式，人们从小就被灌输这一点，这也意味着你不仅强迫自己去扮演一个听起来像是角色的东西，一个听起来像是人格面具的东西，难怪你不知道面具底下到底是谁。你已经进行了24年的方法派表演。就像是以A+的标准进行方法派表演，甚至达到了医生都无法看穿的程度。
Like, that's kind of, like, insane that that's just, that's, like, so hard for me to even comprehend how exhausting that must be. But I think it also, from what I'm hearing from you, comes from this idea that we actually don't know a lot as a general population about what this looks like because of how we've been taught to see it. So that kind of leads to my next question, which is like, what are some of the elements of neurodivergence that you think there needs to be more conversations around that is excluded from the narrative that is maybe less comfortable to speak about or people are less informed about, not because it's rare just because we aren't having conversations about it. Yeah, I think, so in the book, I have like, the first couple of chapters are where I go through, like, the kind of, the kind of, scientific basics of like what actually is ADHD, what actually is autism and what is the diagnostic criteria that a doctor will go through to to decide if you have it or not. But then the next chapter after that is like translating those traits to how they show up in real life. Because I think that's where the education is missing in society of like we understand to a
就像，这简直太疯狂了，我甚至很难理解那会有多筋疲力尽。但从我听你讲述的内容来看，这也源于这样一种观念：由于我们被教导去看待它的方式，作为普通大众，我们其实对这到底是什么样子的了解并不多。所以这自然引出了我的下一个问题，那就是：你认为神经多样性中有哪些元素需要进行更多的讨论，而这些元素却被排斥在叙事之外，或许不那么容易启齿，或者人们对它们了解较少，这不是因为它们罕见，而只是因为我们没有围绕它们展开讨论。是的，我认为，所以在书里，我有前几章是来探讨一些科学基础知识，比如什么是真正的多动症（ADHD），什么是真正的自闭症，以及医生为了决定你是否患有这些疾病而会经历的诊断标准是什么。但接下来的那一章则是将这些特质转化为它们在现实生活中是如何表现的。因为我认为这是社会中所缺失的教育，我们理解到一定
certain level the traits like on paper. But we don't understand how that translates to real life experience, especially in people that aren't the young white boys. So like one example is literal thinking is I think one that we all know that autistic people are literal thinkers. But the way that we've been told of that is like that they don't understand jokes or we don't understand sarcasm or we don't understand like sayings, you know, or it's like, I don't know, break a leg and stuff like that. And they're the examples that are given on like the medical websites and stuff like that. but actually literal thinking and literal processing for me means that I take words as gospel
程度的特质，也就是纸面上的那些。但我们并不理解这如何转化为现实生活中的经验，尤其是对于那些并非年轻白人男孩的人群来说。所以其中一个例子就是字面思维，我认为这是我们都知道的一个例子，即自闭症患者是字面思维者。但我们被告知的方式是，他们听不懂笑话，或者我们听不懂讽刺，或者我们听不懂俗语，你知道的，或者类似于，我不知道，比如“祝你成功”（break a leg）之类的话。这些都是医学网站上给出的例子，
like if someone tells me something I will believe it because they've told me it so I take it very literally that it must be true so even if you know someone when I was younger my parents couldn't say McDonald's out loud because if they said like oh maybe we'll you know if you're good maybe we'll get a McDonald's on the way home I'd be like but you said if I was good, we could have McDonald's and I've been good, so we need to go and get McDonald's.
但实际上，对我而言，字面思维和字面处理意味着我把字面意思奉为圭臬，
You know, like, I would take it very, like, literally what they said. But also, like, it goes the other way of, like, if you haven't told me something, I won't know it to be true because I'm a very literal person. So whereas other people might assume that something's, like, going on in the background or, like, that someone else has got something going on, for example, or that things are happening.
如果有人告诉我什么事情，我就会相信它，因为他们已经告诉我了，所以我非常字面地认为它一定是真的，所以即使你知道某个人，当我更小的时候，我父母不能大声说出麦当劳这个词，因为如果他们说，哦，也许我们，你知道的，如果你表现好，也许我们回家的路上可以买麦当劳，我就会觉得，但是你说了如果我表现好，我们就能吃麦当劳，而且我表现得很好了，所以我们需要去买麦当劳。
if you don't tell me something, then I don't know it. So like, for example, like recently, my dad's had quite a lot going on at work. And like the rest, like, my mum will be like, you know, if he's stressed at home, it's because he's got a lot going on at work. But I'm like, but if he doesn't tell me, you know, other people might be able to think, oh, he's acting different. Maybe something's causing him to act different. Whereas I'm like, but if you don't tell me that you've got a lot going on at work, I don't know that you've got a lot going on at work. So I'm thinking, why is my dad not talking to me or why is my dad seeming stress? Like, what's going on?
你知道的，我会非常字面地理解他们所说的话。但同时，它也会反过来，如果你没有告诉我某事，我就不会认为它是真的，因为我是一个非常字面思维的人。因此，当其他人可能会假设有什么事情在背后发生，或者比如其他人有什么事情正在经历，或者事情正在发生时，
Like, I'm trying to solve that problem. But I don't have the information because no one has said your dad's got a lot on his plate at the moment. So it's that, like, you know, people think, oh yeah, I understand the autistic people, literal thinkers. But it's like, okay, no, but you think that I can't understand sarcasm. But actually, it's that I can only process the world with the information that I am, like, physically given, like in black and white, basically.
如果你不告诉我某事，那么我就不会知道。所以例如，就像最近，我爸爸在工作上有很多事情要处理。然后其余的，我妈妈会说，你知道的，如果他在家里感到压力，那是因为他在工作上有太多事情要处理。但我觉得，如果他没有告诉我，你知道的，其他人可能会觉得，哦，他表现得不一样了。也许有什么事情导致他表现得不同。而我会觉得，但是如果你不告诉我你在工作上有太多事情要处理，我就不知道你在工作上有太多事情要处理。所以我就会想，为什么我爸爸不跟我说话，或者为什么我爸爸看起来压力很大？到底怎么了？
So I think that's like, yeah, people don't understand how the traits actually show up in real life. So I think that's like a big one that I have tried to kind of go through each trait and that way of being like, okay, this is what we think it is and this is how it actually shows up for people. And then I think another really big one, especially with ADHD is RSD, which is rejection sensitive dysphoria. and it's basically like real bad emotional dysregulation and it's like this basically very extreme response in response to kind of perceived or real rejection. So if you think that someone's upset with you or you think that you're being rejected
就像，我正在努力解决那个问题。但我没有信息，因为没有人说“你爸爸目前手头有很多事情要处理”。所以就是那种，你知道的，人们会觉得，哦，是的，我理解自闭症患者，他们是字面思维者。但这就好比，不，但你以为我听不懂讽刺。然而实际上，我只能用我被给予的信息来处理这个世界，也就是物理上给出的信息，基本上就是非黑即白的。
or you think that you haven't done a good job or anything is like pointing you in the direction of some sort of perceived rejection, then it's like a full body. Like it feels like the world is closing in on you because you've just been rejected in that way. And I think that's a big one as to why so many women don't get diagnosed or they do throw the anxiety card or the depression card
所以我认为这就是，是的，人们不理解这些特质如何在现实生活中真正表现出来。所以我认为这是一个很大的方面，我试图浏览每一个特质并以这种方式去阐述，即：好的，这就是我们认为它是怎样的，而这就是它对人们实际产生的影响。然后我认为另一个非常重大的方面，尤其是对于多动症（ADHD）而言，就是RSD，也就是拒绝敏感性 dysphoria（情绪失调），
because all they're seeing, again, is these like extreme emotional reactions and they're like hormones, anxiety, like all of these things. Or like, or BPD as well. Like, yeah. That would be another one where I'm like, that slots in. Yeah. So I actually, yeah, when I, so before I got to my actual diagnosis,
它基本上就是非常严重的情绪失调，这是一种针对某种觉察到或真实的拒绝所产生的极其极端的反应。所以如果你觉得有人对你不满，或者你觉得自己被拒绝了，
when I kind of got to the point where I was like, hmm, anxiety's not quite right, but I didn't have the answers yet. I actually went through, there was like a couple months where I was convinced that I had BPD. I was like, I started researching online and that was the first thing that came up.
或者你觉得你没有做好工作，或者任何事情都在将你引向某种觉察到的拒绝，那么它就会是一种全身心的反应。感觉整个世界都在向你合拢，因为你刚刚以那种方式被拒绝了。我认为这是为什么那么多女性没有得到诊断，或者被贴上焦虑标签或抑郁标签的一个重要原因，
Like, you know, mood swings, going from being really high to being really low, like kind of irrational behavior. And like, when someone's leaving, like, you know, having abandonment. and I was like, that's me. I was like, all of these things are me. I found the answer. Like, I've got BPD and I was like literally going to my doctors. I was like, I need to be referred for a BPD assessment. Like I've got BPD like, I found the answer. This is it. And they're like,
因为她们看到的依然是这些极端的激进情绪反应，然后她们会说这是荷尔蒙、焦虑，所有这些事情。或者还有，比如边缘型人格障碍（BPD）。就像，是的。那会是另一个我觉得能够契合的例子。所以实际上，是的，当我，所以在得到我的实际诊断之前，
no, Ellie, it's not. Like that's not you. And I was like, no, but it is. It is. And like, I mean, I guess it isn't. But yeah, the experiences, like I read those traits. And I was like, that's me, that's me, that's me. And it's literal as well, like you said. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. And I think what makes it even more, I was actually having this conversation with a friend yesterday, what makes it even more difficult is that things like BPD and C PTSD are caused by trauma. And growing up as an undiagnosed autistic person
当我到达那种觉得，嗯，焦虑似乎不太对劲，但我还没有答案的时候。我实际上经历过，有几个月我确信自己患有边缘型人格障碍（BPD）。我当时想，我开始在网上搜索，那是我搜到的第一个结果。
or undiagnosed person with ADHD, that is trauma in itself. You're masking all the time, you're living in a world that's not designed for you. You're constantly misunderstood. You're constantly told that what you're, like if you're yourself, it's wrong. You're constantly told that you're lazy or that you're sensitive or all of these things.
就像，你知道的，情绪波动，从极度高涨跌落到极度低落，类似于不理智的行为。而且，当有人离开时，你知道的，会有被抛弃感。而我觉得，那正是我。我心想，所有这些情况都正是我。我找到答案了。我得了边缘型人格障碍，我简直要去找我的医生。我跟他们说，我需要转诊去进行边缘型人格障碍评估。我得了边缘型人格障碍，我已经找到答案了。就是这个。然后他们说：
like growing up as an undiagnosed neurodivergent person is trauma and these other conditions that are so similar in their experiences are caused by trauma so it's like how the heck are you supposed to disentangle like it's so common for people to have a combination of all of these things like I am almost certain that I've got C PTSD because just the things that like happened in my teenage years and the way that I respond now to things that happen versus like it's not, I'm not just dealing with the thing that's happening. I'm dealing with all of the stuff that happened
不，艾莉，不是的。那不是你。而我会说，不，但它就是。它就是。而且，我的意思是，我想它确实不是。但确实，这些经历，我阅读了那些特质。然后我觉得，那就是我，那就是我，那就是我。而且正如你所说，这也是字面意义上的。是的。是的，完全如此。而且我认为让它变得更困难的是——我昨天刚和一位朋友进行过这样的对话——让它变得更困难的是，像边缘型人格障碍和复杂性创伤后应激障碍（C-PTSD）这些东西是由创伤引起的。作为一个未确诊的自闭症患者在成长过程中，
when I was undiagnosed, but the actual experience it, like it'd be really difficult for me to get diagnosed with CPTSD because they could probably explain away all of the experiences that I was having through ADHD emotional dysregulation, rejecting sensitive dysphoria, through autism, like being hypervigilant.
或者作为一个未确诊的注意力缺陷多动障碍患者，这本身就是一种创伤。你一直在伪装，你生活在一个并非为你设计的世界里。你不断被误解。你不断被告知，你所做的，如果你做你自己，那就是错的。你不断被告知你很懒惰，或者你很敏感，所有这些事情。
That's, again, like, I'm autistic, so I have, yeah, I'm autistic so I pick up on things really easily and I'm really sensitive to sound and I'm really sensitive to change and I like to have a routine and all of those things also are behaviours that people with CPTSD would show because it's hypervigilance,
作为一个未确诊的神经多样性人群成长是一种创伤，而这些在经历上如此相似的其他病症也是由创伤引起的，所以这就好像，你到底该如何去厘清它们——人们同时拥有所有这些组合情况是如此普遍，就像我几乎可以确信我患有复杂性创伤后应激障碍（C-PTSD），因为仅仅是我十几岁时发生的那些事情，以及我现在对发生的事情的反应方式，与——这不仅仅是，我不只是在处理正在发生的事情。我正在处理所有那些发生的事情，
it's protecting yourself, it's all of those things like it is just a mind field of like overlap and complication and I think yeah that's a really kind of big thing that a lot of people face of like what is going on here and a lot of the time it's probably a bit of a combination of everything.
当我未被确诊时，但实际的经历，就像，我要被诊断出患有C-PTSD将会非常困难，因为他们很可能会把我的所有经历都归咎于ADHD的情绪失调、拒绝敏感性 dysphoria，或者归咎于自闭症，比如过度警觉。
So interesting as well because it's only been recently that people can actually get more than one diagnoses. Like it used to be like here you have bipolar disorder, you have borderline personality disorder, you have autism, there's your box, sit in it now. And I think you point to a really interesting point that a lot of people don't understand, which is that your experience with mental illness can actually create further mental illness and actually can be a trigger for things like complex post. post-traumatic stress disorder.
这，再次说明，我是自闭症患者，所以我，是的，我是自闭症患者，所以我能非常轻易地察觉到事情，我对声音极其敏感，我对变化极其敏感，我喜欢有规律的生活，所有这些行为同时也体现了患有C-PTSD的人所表现出来的行为，因为那是过度警觉，
I think we often think about that in particular. I really like that you brought that in. We think about trauma in the sense of something really, really terrible, external, violent happening to you. But trauma is just like the disruption of security and peace and, you know, safety. That is as simple as it is. And that can come from so many different things, including like an experience of growing up,
那是保护你自己，所有这些事情就像是一个重叠和复杂的雷区，而且我认为，是的，这是许多人面临的一个非常重大的问题，即这里到底发生了什么？而很多时候，它可能是一切因素的某种组合。
in, as you said, a world that is not designed for you. That is so traumatic. And it's not just one of it. It's a continuous accumulation of stress, of anxiety, of, as you said, masking. So I'm glad that you brought that up. And I think it really leads into this next thing, which is, if I'm sure, I'm so sure that there is probably someone listening to this right now who was like, holy shit. Why is this describing me? I thought I had BPD.
这也非常有趣，因为人们实际上直到最近才能获得一个以上的诊断。过去的情况就像是：给你，你有双相情感障碍，你有边缘型人格障碍，你有自闭症，这就是你的盒子，现在坐进去吧。而且我认为你指出了一个非常有趣的点，很多人并不理解，那就是你对精神疾病的经历实际上可以产生更多的精神疾病，并且实际上可以成为诸如复杂性创伤后应激障碍之类事情的诱因。
Everyone told me I had anxiety. I said rude things when I was a teenager without realizing it, without even consciously knowing. So what would your advice be to someone who thinks that they have ADHD, they have autism, they're in the same position as you, now that they're an adult in their 20s. Like you said, there's going to be so many more people who are coming through in the next few decades who could have received a diagnosis at 3, 9, 10.
我想我们经常特别关注这一点。我很喜欢你把它引入进来。我们认为的创伤是指某种非常非常糟糕的、外部的、暴力的事情发生在你身上。但创伤其实就是安全感、平静以及，你知道的，安全感的瓦解。事情就是这么简单。它可以来自很多不同的事情，包括成长过程中的经历，正如你所说，在一个不为你设计的世界里。那真是太具创伤性了。而且不仅仅是一次。它是压力、焦虑的持续累积，正如你所说，还有伪装。所以我很高兴你提出了这一点。而且我认为这确实引出了接下来的内容，也就是，如果我确信，我非常确信现在肯定有人正在听这个节目，心想：卧槽。为什么这在描述我？我还以为我有边缘型人格障碍呢。
but aren't going to do so until they're 20. What's your advice as someone who kind of lived that? Yeah, I think it's a really, really tricky one now because because of the fact that so many more people are realizing, it means that services and support just aren't there. Like the waiting list to get an actual diagnosis are so long. It's so tricky to get diagnosed. And also the medical professionals are kind of a lot of the time behind us
但要等到他们20岁才去做。作为过来人，你有什么建议？是的，我觉得现在这真的非常非常棘手，因为有越来越多的人意识到了这一点，这意味着服务和支持根本跟不上。比如获得实际诊断的等待名单太长了。要得到诊断太难了。而且医疗专业人员在我们的理解方面很多时候也落后了
in our understanding. like they were trained however many years ago when they were at university or whatever it might be. They were taught the stereotypical diagnostic criteria. They were taught that it was more common in cis boys than it wasn't anybody else. You know, they maybe don't have the understanding to be able to see your experiences and see them for what they are. That's if you're even kind of lucky enough to get in the room with somebody. like now waiting lists are really long and like private assessments are really expensive like it's a really tricky time at the moment because it's like so many people are having these realizations and then they
他们可能是在多年前上大学或接受培训时学的。他们学的是刻板的诊断标准。他们被教导说这在顺性别男孩中比在其他人中更常见。你知道，他们可能没有足够的理解能力来看待你的经历并认清其本质。这还得建立在你幸运能够见到医生的前提下。就像现在等待名单真的很长，私人评估也非常昂贵，所以目前这是一个非常棘手的时候，因为很多人有了这种认识，然后他们
they can't really go away and do anything with that so I would say like my first point is like that self-diagnosis is completely valid and is kind of necessary in the current world that we live in I think with ADHD it's slightly different because medication can be helpful and obviously you would need to see and have a medical diagnosis and see a professional for that. But other than that, like, you are the expert of your own experiences. If you're going through all of this information, if you're doing all of these online tests and you're seeing that, yeah, this is right for me,
却无法真正去做任何事情，所以我认为我的第一点是，自我诊断是完全有效的，在我们生活的当今世界可以说是必需的。我认为对于ADHD来说情况略有不同，因为药物可能会有帮助，显然你需要去看医生并获得医疗诊断以及专业人员的帮助。但除此之外，你是你自己经历的专家。如果你正在消化所有这些信息，如果你在做所有这些在线测试，并且你发现，是的，这正适合我，
this is who I am, then you can tell you, you can give yourself that answer. You don't need to have like a green tick of approval from a medical professional because it's just, you know, in an ideal world, yes, we would all be able to go and see a psychiatrist and get those answers, but we don't live in an ideal. world. We live in a world where it's impossible to do that for a lot of people at the moment, and it's a privilege to be able to do that. So, like, firstly, yeah, that's completely a valid
这正是我，那么你就可以告诉自己，你可以给自己那个答案。你不需要得到医疗专业人员的绿灯批准，因为你知道，在理想世界里，是的，我们本都可以去看精神科医生并得到那些答案，但我们并不生活在理想世界中。我们生活在一个对许多人来说目前根本无法做到这一点的世界，能做到这一点是一种特权。所以，首先，是的，这完全是一个有效的
thing to do. And also, like, remembering that it's not a piece of paper from a doctor that changes your life. It's changing your life that changes your life. So it's like, I, you know, anyone can change the way that they're working. They can work more flexibly. They can give themselves more rest. They can honor their sensory needs more. They can wear, ear defenders when they're in noisy venues they can buy planners that will help them manage their time better they can you know all of these things that are the reason that my life is so much better now anyone can do it doesn't need a doctor to go yes you are autistic yes you have ADHD for you to be able to do those things so I think it's really you know there's a this narrative at the
做法。而且，还要记住，改变你生活的不是医生开的一张纸，而是你对生活的改变。所以，任何人都可以改变他们的工作方式。他们可以更灵活地工作。他们可以让自己多休息。他们可以更多地满足自己的感官需求。当他们在嘈杂的场所时，他们可以戴上降噪耳塞，他们可以购买能帮助他们更好地管理时间的日程本，你知道所有这些让我的生活现在变得好得多的原因，任何人都可以做到，不需要医生去说“是的，你是自闭症患者，是的，你有ADHD”，你才能去做这些事情。所以我认为真的，目前有一种
moment that like oh everyone's self-diagnosing and you have to you know you don't know but like you do that for yourself and I would say the main thing as well that helps you know me in terms of like validation and actually understanding and feeling comfortable in knowing that that was what was going on for me um was looking like searching out the experiences of other people that had similar lived experience to mine so yeah like we were saying when i was reading through the diagnostic criteria there were some things where i was like hmm you know maybe that's me but it doesn't 100% sound like me but then i would go on to social media and i would find another 20-something year old woman talking about her experience of that thing and I'd be like oh yeah that's
这样的言论，说什么“哦，每个人都在自我诊断，你必须……你根本不懂”，但你是在为自己这样做。我想说的最主要的事情，也是在认可度、真正理解并安心确知这就是我所经历的方面帮助过我的，呃，是去寻找和我有相似生活经历的其他人的经历。所以，就像我们之前说的，当我阅读诊断标准时，有些事情我会觉得，嗯，也许这就是我，但这并不百分之百符合我。但随后我会上社交媒体，找到另一个二十多岁的女性在谈论她对那件事的经历，然后我会想：“哦，对了，那
just like me I do that I'm exactly the same as that because obviously if we're both the same age the same gender and we have similar interests then the way that our traits show up are going to be more similar as well so I think that's a really helpful thing to do you know if you're a woman look for the experiences of women if you're a person of color look for the experiences of people of color if you're a mother look for the experiences of other mothers like look for people who have similar, like a wider range of similar experience to yours, then the way that their traits show up is probably more likely to going to be more similar to yours as well.
就跟我一样，我也那样，我跟她完全一样。”因为很明显，如果我们年龄相同、性别相同，而且有相似的兴趣，那么我们的特质表现出来的方式也会更相似。所以我觉得这是一件非常有帮助的事情，如果你是女性，就去寻找女性的经历；如果你是有色人种，就去寻找有色人种的经历；如果你是一位母亲，就去寻找其他母亲的经历。去寻找那些拥有相似、更广泛的与你相似经历的人，那么他们的特质表现出来的方式可能也更有可能与你的非常相似。
So I think that's a really helpful, that for me, that was like what kind of tipped me over the edge from, hmm, maybe, maybe I should look into these things to, yeah, I'm confident that this is what's going on for me, was seeing other people who were similar to me talking about their experiences because they were obviously a lot more similar to mine. So I would say that that is like the best thing that I could recommend. It's like a far from ideal situation because it's like I obviously would love for everybody
所以我认为这真的很有帮助，对我来说，这就像是让我从“嗯，也许，也许我应该了解一下这些事情”转变为“是的，我很确信这就是我正在经历的”的关键所在，因为我看到了和我相似的人在谈论他们的经历，而这些经历显然和我的要相似得多。所以我要说这是我能推荐的最好的事情。这远非理想的情况，因为显然我希望每个人
to be able to get the actual answers and the support that they need and the medication that they need for ADHD if they choose to do that. But it's a tricky time at the moment where these services are just overloaded. So I think just like knowing like that it's okay to self-diagnose, that it's okay to put these things in place for yourself without someone. telling you that you're allowed to do that. And then also seeking out the experience. And even like connecting with other neurodivergent people where you can. Like for me, obviously I'm kind of very public about it. It's my job to talk about it online.
都能得到他们需要的实际答案、支持，如果他们选择这样做的话，还能得到治疗ADHD所需的药物。但目前这是一个棘手的时期，这些服务已经超负荷了。所以我觉得只要知道自我诊断是可以的，在没有人允许的情况下，为自己做出这些安排也是可以的。然后去寻找相关的经历。甚至尽可能与其他神经多样性人群建立联系。比如对我来说，显然我对这很公开。在线上谈论这个就是我的工作。
But the friends I have made through doing that and having autistic friends, ADHD friends, has literally been the best thing that has ever happened to me in my entire life. Like I've always had such a hard time with friendships. Like school was awful for me. Like I think I massively underestimate it actually where it's been one of those things where I've just had to survive it. So I just, I'm like, we don't talk about school.
但通过这样做以及结交自闭症朋友、ADHD朋友而交到的朋友，简直是我一生中发生过的最好的事情。我一直觉得交朋友太难了。学校对我的伤害太大了。我觉得我实际上严重低估了它，它一直是那种我只能咬牙挺过去的事情。所以我只会说，我们不谈论学校。
We don't think about it. Like, I dropped out of school. I had, I was bullied awfully. Like, I just had an awful time. And I guess I just kind of got used to the fact that, okay, maybe I'm never going to find a friendship group. Maybe I'm never going to fit in anywhere because it just doesn't seem to have happened up to now.
我们不去想它。我从学校辍学了。我遭受了可怕的霸凌。我度过了一段糟糕的时光。我想我只是习惯了这样一个事实：好吧，也许我永远也找不到一个朋友圈。也许我永远也无法融入任何地方，因为到目前为止这似乎根本没有发生过。
Whereas now I'm like, oh, no, I actually can find people that I relate to. I was just not finding the right people. And so I think if you can, join communities. I have another Instagram account called We Are Onmast, which is a community for neurodivergent people, and we try and set up an event. It's kind of on the back burner at the moment because I've been writing a book and stuff. But yeah, hopefully we'll be doing more like online events and things like that. And even just looking through the comments, you'll be able to find people who are in a similar position to you. And I think finding those friendships is like a huge thing that you can do for validation as well.
而现在我想，哦，不，我其实可以找到我能共情的人。我只是以前没有找到对的人。所以我想如果可以的话，加入社群。我有另一个名为“We Are Onmast”的Instagram账号，这是一个面向神经多样性人群的社群，我们尝试举办活动。目前它处于搁置状态，因为我一直在写书之类的。但是的，希望我们以后会做更多像线上活动之类的事情。甚至只要浏览评论区，你就能找到处境与你相似的人。我认为寻找这些友谊对于获得认可来说也是一件大事。
A hundred percent. I honestly love that. not just, I obviously don't have ADHD or autism, but like even from my perspective, if you can relate to that, like, the best is yet to come. Like, you're not going to find your people in a high school of 600 people, 600 people. Like, maybe you will, but the world is so much bigger and broader and wider than that. You have no idea what's coming and not in an anxious sense and like the most beautiful sense. And also, I really like that point because I think in the cycle,
百分之百。我真的很喜欢这个观点。不仅是……我显然没有ADHD或自闭症，但即使从我的角度来看，如果你能对此产生共鸣，那么最美好的还在后头。你不会在一个只有600人的高中里找到属于你的圈子。也许你会，但世界要比那大得多、广阔得多、包容得多。你根本不知道未来会发生什么，这不是指焦虑意义上的，而是指最美好的那种意义上。而且，我也真的很喜欢那个观点，因为我认为在循环中，
the point you made earlier in like the psychology community there is a big fuss around like ADHD is so overdiagnosed everyone's on you know riddalen or adderall whatever and I'm like okay great are you their doctor no so you have no opinion on this you literally you're someone on the internet who has made their mind up around what this does and doesn't look look like and I think that is so insulting and it's additionally the thing of like I always think about the comparison to depression. You can know you're depressed without a doctor telling you and you can do things in your life to mitigate that. What is to say that you can't do that for other things as well? And obviously medication comes into it. You might need a helping hand in that sense, but
你刚才提到的观点，在心理学界有一个很大的争论，围绕着诸如“ADHD被过度诊断了，每个人都在吃利他林或阿德拉”之类的话题，而我想说，好吧，太棒了，你是他们的医生吗？不是，所以你对此没有发言权。你只是互联网上一个对这东西到底是什么样、什么样不是做出自己判断的人，我认为这太侮辱人了。这另外让我想到了与抑郁症的对比。你不需要医生告诉你，你就能知道自己得了抑郁症，你可以在生活中做一些事情来缓解它。凭什么说你不能对其他事情也这样做呢？显然药物也是其中一部分。在这个意义上你可能需要一只援助之手，但
it doesn't mean that you have to wait until someone goes, yeah, you're like approved for a diagnosis to be making the changes that you think are going to benefit your life. So I think that's such a beautiful message. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when they're is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这并不意味着你必须等到有人说“好的，你获准确诊了”才能去做出你认为会有益于你生活的改变。所以我认为这是一个非常美丽的讯息。2%的人在有自动扶梯可用时会选择走楼梯。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上有发炎性。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast.
我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO percent”。你还记得当黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上拍打小吉姆的胸部时吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小吉姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，他滔滔不绝地谈论着80年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在某天谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现这里有一条主线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域的十多年经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某事的过程中，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。我们还在继续追逐，却不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要吗？
Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app.
还是说你当个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的发自内心地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难成长》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
搜索《艰难成长》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法律战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
你对某人的这个特定测试篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。吉尔斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. One final question that I would love for you to answer is you've just released a book. I know we've talked about it so much. And I honestly hearing your story of being like I had to drop out of high school, I was bullied, I never thought I was going to get that far. And that's, and here you are now is like, honestly quite emotional. So what would you tell that person, that kind of younger
随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里icopa县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被大陪审团以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的那个地方收听《陷入爱河》播客。我想请你回答的最后一个问题是，你刚刚出版了一本书。我知道我们已经谈论了很多。说实话，听到你的故事，说你不得不从高中辍学，你被霸凌，你从未想过自己能走到这一步。而现在你却站在这里，老实说这相当让人情绪激动。所以你会对那个人，对那个年幼的、
version of you who was really struggling for answers? Yeah, I think a big one is like, focus on the people that love you rather than the ones that don't. So I think like, especially through high school, I think like obviously I didn't know that I was masking. I didn't know that I was autistic or that I had ADHD. But I always had, it was almost like an internal thing where I always tried to become friends with the popular people. I think it was like this innate need to fit in,
真正为寻找答案而苦苦挣扎的你自己说些什么？是的，我觉得很大的一点是：关注那些爱你的的人，而不是那些不爱你的人。所以我认为，特别是在高中期间，显然我当时并不知道自己在伪装。我不知道自己有自闭症或ADHD。但我一直有一种，这几乎是一种内在的东西，我总是试图和受欢迎的人交朋友。我想这是一种融入其中的内在需求，
this innate need to be liked to be approved of, like to be validated, that I would always, like try and be friends with the popular group and it would always end badly for me like I had so many time I could probably point to like 10 different times in my life where I've sat down with my mum and she's been like Ellie why do you always try to be friends with like the loud girls the popular girls like they're not like you like you're you're soft you're gentle like it's it doesn't end well for you like why and it was almost like I think like all kind of women and people marginalized for their gender that have gone through high school know that feeling of like it's a rock and a hard place like
这种被喜欢、被认可、被肯定的内在需求，让我总是试图和受欢迎的小团体交朋友，而这总是以糟糕的结局收场。我有过很多次，我大概能指出我人生中大约10个不同的时刻，我和我妈妈坐在一起，她会问：“埃莉，你为什么总是试图和那些喧闹的女孩、受欢迎的女孩交朋友？她们和你不一样，你是温和的、温柔的，这不会有好结果的，为什么？”这就好像，我想所有经历过高中的女性和因性别而被边缘化的人都知道那种感觉，就像是进退维谷——
It's like the plastics in Mingo. Like if you're friends with them, then it's life as hell. But if you're not friends with them, then it's even worse. So I think it was that thing of like, I would always try to be liked by everybody and by the popular people. Whereas actually, if I'd have got there on my first day in year seven and gone, I actually really like maths. I actually really like puzzles.
就像《贱女孩》里的塑料姐妹花。如果你和她们做朋友，那生活就像在地狱里一样。但如果你不和她们做朋友，情况就会更糟。所以我觉得就是那种心态，我总是试图让所有人和受欢迎的人都喜欢我。而事实上，如果我在七年级的头一天走进学校说：我其实真的很喜欢数学。我其实真的很喜欢拼图。
I, you know, maybe I should make some friends that maybe other people are going to call us weird. Maybe we're not going to have the nicest time either. But I'm at least going to have these three. solid friends that we all love each other for our weirdness and our geekiness and our strangeness and all of whatever it might be like that would have been it still wouldn't have been easy right because no one has a nice time at high school especially if you're like different in any way but at least i would have had like that solid group of friends that would have loved me for me whereas i was so like focused on making everybody like me or trying to fit in with the popular
我，你知道，也许我应该交一些朋友，也许其他人会叫我们怪胎。也许我们的日子也不会太好过。但我至少会有这三位坚定的朋友，我们都因为彼此的古怪、书呆子气、奇异之处而深爱着对方，无论那可能是什么——那样的话，日子依然不会好过，对吧？因为在高中没人能过得轻松，尤其是如果你在任何方面与众不同的话。但至少我会有那个坚定的小团体，他们会因为我本来的样子而爱我，而我当时却如此专注于让所有人都喜欢我，或者试图融入受欢迎的人群中。
the people that I kind of denied myself the opportunity to make friends that might not have been as popular, but they would have been friends. So I think that would be my thing of like, focus on finding people that love you for you rather than being like, it's that thing of like, don't be everyone's cup of tea, be like someone's shot of whiskey or I don't know whatever the saying is of like basically like. Oh, I've never heard that, but I love that. I'm going to slow that bro. I don't even know if that's right. We've made it up now. We'll go with it. But yeah, yeah, kind of that thing of like trying to focus on finding a place rather than being like mass liked I think would have been a good one for me to know and I think almost like I think it's one of those
我当时剥夺了自己去结交那些可能不那么受欢迎、但会成为真正的朋友的机会。所以我想这会是我的感悟：专注于寻找那些因为你是你自己而爱你的人，而不是去追求那种“不要做所有人的杯中茶，要做某人的烈性威士忌”或者别的什么俗语，基本上就是……哦，我从没听说过那个，但我太喜欢了。我要把它记下来，兄弟。我甚至不知道这话对不对。我们现在自己编的。那就这样吧。不过是的，那种试着专注于找到一个归属地，而不是去追求大众喜爱的心态，我觉得如果我早点知道就好了，而且我觉得这几乎就像是
things where it's like it's a worst thing that someone can say to you at the time but over time you realize that it's so true of just like trusting the process like I genuinely thought that because I didn't go to uni because I dropped out of school like that was it I was never going to get anywhere in life like I was going to be miserable I was going to do low paid jobs I was never never going to be successful, I was going to be overworked, like when actually, you know, I've been really lucky, I'm really grateful for what's happened, but I've not needed a degree for any of this. Like, I've not needed high school qualifications for any of this. It has all worked out in the end. And like maybe it could have worked out a lot sooner, but I think just like trusting that you don't
那种当时觉得别人对你说的最糟糕的话，但随着时间推移，你会发现它是如此真实，那就是相信过程。我真的以为，因为我没上大学，因为我辍学了，我的人生就此完了，我永远不会在生活中有所成就，我会过得很悲惨，我会去做低薪工作，我永远不会成功，我会过度劳累。而实际上，你知道的，我真的很幸运，我很感激所发生的一切，但我根本不需要学位来做这些。我根本不需要高中学历来做这些。结果一切都顺其自然了。也许这一切可以更早实现，但我觉得只要相信你不需要
have to do things the way that everyone else is doing them. Like you can do what is better that you drop out and you're still healthy and you're, well, you're working on becoming healthy again and you're looking after yourself and you're being gentle with yourself, then forcing yourself to do things because you think that you should do them and you think that's the only way that you're going to achieve anything and all of that stuff. And I guess, yeah, redefining the path and redefining what success is, I think was, because I think, yeah, at school there's so much pressure of like you have to be the top grade student. You have to go to uni.
像其他人那样按部就班地做事。你可以选择对你来说更好的方式，如果你辍学了，你依然很健康，或者说，你正在努力恢复健康，你照顾好自己，你对温柔以待自己，总好过强迫自己去做那些你认为自己“应该”去做的事，并且认为那是你取得成就的唯一途径等等。我想，是的，重新定义人生道路和成功，因为我觉得，学校里有太多的压力，你必须成为成绩最好的学生。你必须去上大学。
You have to get a good job. And that doesn't work for everybody. Like life happens. And also that life is not the life that everyone wants. So I think if someone would have been like, it's okay if you're not. top of the class. It's okay if you don't go to uni. That would have been a really helpful thing for me to know as well. Oh, trust the process. I love that. Also, totally true. Like, it's, there is such a different path than the jobs that we might be working at like 20 years probably don't exist yet.
你必须找一份好工作。但这并不适合所有人。生活总会有意想不到的波折。而且那种生活也不是每个人都想要的生活。所以我想，如果当时有人能对我说，即使你不是班里的尖子生也没关系。即使你不上大学也没关系。这对我来说也是一个非常有用的道理。哦，相信过程。我太喜欢这句话了。而且完全正确。我们的生活道路大不相同，我们20年后的工作现在可能甚至还不存在。
What you and I doing did not exist 20 years ago. Like, maybe what I'm doing, like technically podcast did exist, but not to this level. Like, the world is evolving and I think that's so important. I always think is like I'm most grateful for the things that I wanted and didn't get. Like I'm so grateful for the things that I like begged for that I thought were going to make me happy, like that internship, that like, you know, university entry, that boyfriend. And I didn't get them. And at the time I was like, I'm so miserable. This is the end of my life. And everything, I know, I hate saying everything happens for a reason because I don't think it does. But there are some things that happen for you, not to you. I think that's.
你和我现在做的事情在20年前根本不存在。也许我做的，从技术上讲播客是存在的，但没有达到这种水平。世界在不断演变，我觉得这太重要了。我总是觉得，我最感激的是那些我曾苦苦追求却最终没有得到的东西。我非常感激那些我曾经苦求、以为会带给我快乐的东西，比如那个实习机会、那个大学录取通知、那个男朋友。而我没有得到它们。当时我觉得我太惨了。这简直是我人生的终点。我知道，我讨厌说“一切发生皆有原因”，因为我不认为每件事都是如此。但确实有些事情发生是为了成就你，而不是为了击垮你。我觉得这是
like a beautiful way to end things. So I want to say thank you so much for coming on. Thank you for being one of our guests for this like wonderful December holiday series. It's just like such a beautiful perspective one that I think more people need to hear. And I'm so so thankful that you're able to make time to talk to us. Yeah, thank you so much for having me. It's been so nice to have a very nice, wholesome chat to start the day for me. Yeah. And to end the day for me. Yeah. And to end the day for me. Look at that. It's like a beautiful bookmark for our days. I'm going to put all of Ellie's links in the description here. Please go and buy her book. If you, if you resonate with any of this, if you have a friend, a family member who this sounds like them. Buy it for them. It's Christmas time.
一个完美的收尾方式。所以我想非常感谢你来到这里。谢谢你成为我们12月精彩节日系列特辑的嘉宾之一。这真是一个美妙的视角，我认为更多的人需要听到它。我非常非常感谢你能抽出时间来和我们聊聊。是的，非常感谢邀请我。能有这样一场非常美好、温馨的谈话来开启我的一天，感觉太棒了。是的。而且是以完美的方式结束我的一天。是的。为我的一天画上句号。你看。这就像是我们日子的一个美丽书签。我会在下方的说明栏中附上艾莉的所有链接。请去买她的书。如果你、如果你对其中的任何内容产生共鸣，如果你有朋友或家人有着相似的经历。为他们买一本吧。圣诞节快到了。
Why the fuck not? You know, share the joy around. Share the information around. And as always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify. Wherever you're listening right now, share it with a friend if you think they'd like. like it. And if you have any further questions, comments, if you have an opinion on this episode or an episode's suggestion, please feel free to follow us at that psychology podcast. And we'll see you again later this week. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
为什么不呢？你知道的，把这份喜悦分享出去。把这些信息传递出去。一如既往，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在苹果播客或声破天上留下五星好评。无论你现在在哪里收听，如果你觉得朋友会喜欢，就分享给他们吧。如果你有任何进一步的问题、评论，如果你对这期节目有看法或有节目建议，请随时关注我们的“那个心理学播客”。我们本周晚些时候再见。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗挫力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。就在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。听听好姐妹的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。在《回顾过去》播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here. unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一期节目，我们都会带你来到这里，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起，理清我们是如何熬过那段日期的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。那真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest, conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the
我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难学理》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不敢进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身穿盔甲。这向
world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the iHeard radio app, Apple podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an iHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
全世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要使用它。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学理》。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。